we know that the best way to protect
americans ultimately is going to stop
this outbreak at the source
and i just had
the privilege of speaking with some of
the men and women
who are working to do just that
our disaster assistance response team on
the ground in west africa
first and foremost i thank them for
their incredible dedication and
compassion
these are the folks that
from the minute that we saw this ebola
outbreak
growing larger than we had seen
traditionally were deployed were on the
ground
and we're helping to coordinate
the countries where the outbreak is
happening to make sure that the response
was effective
and it's typical of what america does
best
when others are in trouble
when disease or disaster strikes
americans help and no other nation is
doing as much
to make sure that we contain and
ultimately
eliminate this outbreak than america
we deployed this dart team to west
africa back in early august
they're now
the strategic and operational backbone
of america's response
they've increased the number of ebola
treatment units and burial teams they've
expanded the pipeline of medical
personnel and equipment and supplies
they've launched an aggressive education
campaign
in country
the bottom line is is that they're doing
what it takes to make sure that
medical personnel and health care
workers from all countries have what
they need to get the job done and the
good news is that it's starting to have
an impact based on the conversations
that i had today with them they're
starting to see
some progress in liberia and the
infrastructure is beginning to get built
out that's thanks to
the incredible work and dedication
of folks from the united states who are
leading the way in helping liberia
guinea and sierra leone
and it's critical that we maintain that
leadership
the truth is
that we're going to have to stay
vigilant here at home until we stop the
epidemic at its source
and for that we're going to need to make
sure that our doctors and our health
care professionals here in the united
states
are properly trained and informed
and that they are coordinated if and
when
an ebola case crops up here in the
united states
but
what's also critically important is
making sure that all the talent skill
compassion professionalism dedication
and experience
of our folks here can be deployed to
help those countries
deal with this outbreak at the source
and that's why yesterday the cdc
announced
that we're going to have new monitoring
and movement guidance that is sensible
based in science and tailored to the
unique circumstances of each health
worker that may be returning from one of
these countries after they have provided
the kind of help that they need
in fact tomorrow i'm going to have a
chance to meet with doctors and public
health workers who've already returned
from fighting this disease in west
africa or who are about to go
not only to say thank you to them and
give them encouragement but to make sure
that we're getting input from them based
on the science based on the facts based
on experience about how
the battle to deal with ebola is going
and how our policies can support
the incredible heroism
that they are showing
so
we don't want to discourage our health
care workers from
going to the front lines and dealing
with this in an effective way
our medical teams here are getting
better and better prepared and trained
for
the possibility of
an isolated ebola case
here in the united states but in the
meantime we've got to make sure that we
continue to provide the support
of health workers who are going overseas
to deal with the disease where it really
has
been raging
it's also important for the american
people to remind themselves that
only two people so far have contracted
ebola on american soil
the two dallas nurses who treated a
patient who contracted it in west africa
today both of them are disease-free
i met with one of them nina pham
uh last week and she uh is doing
wonderfully
and i just had a chance to get off the
phone with amber vinson
who is on her way back home uh and also
as many of you saw in her
uh press
statement today uh is doing well also
of the seven americans treated for ebola
so far
all have survived
right now the only american
still undergoing treatment is dr craig
spencer who contracted the disease
abroad while working to protect others
and we should be saluting his service
and we are focused on getting him the
best care possible as well and our
thoughts and prayers are with him
meanwhile the west african nations of
senegal and nigeria have now been
declared ebola-free that's in part
because of outstanding work
led in many cases by americans working
in coordination with those countries to
make sure that we did not see an
outbreak there
so the point is is that this disease can
be contained
it will be defeated
progress
is possible
but
we're going to have to stay vigilant
and we've got to make sure that we're
working together
we have to keep leading the global
response america cannot look like it is
shying away because other people are
watching what we do
and if we don't have
a robust international response in west
africa
then we are actually endangering
ourselves here back home
in order to do that we've got to make
sure that those workers who are willing
and able and dedicated to go over there
in a really tough job
that they're applauded thanked and
supported
that should be our priority
and we can make sure that when they come
back they are being monitored in a
prudent fashion
but we want to make sure that we
understand that they are doing
god's work over there
and they're doing that to keep us safe
and and i want to make sure that every
policy we put in place is supportive of
their efforts because if they are
successful then we're not going to have
to worry about ebola here at home
america in the end is not defined by
fear
that's not who we are
america is defined by possibility and
when we see a problem and we see a
challenge then we fix it
we don't just react
based on
our fears
we react based on facts and judgment
and and making smart decisions that's
how
we have built this country and sustained
this country and protected this country
that's why america has defined progress
because we're not afraid when challenges
come up
thanks to our military our dedicated
medical and health care professionals
the men and women who i spoke to today
in west africa that leadership and
progress continues
and we're going to keep on making
progress and we're going to solve this
particular problem just like we've
solved every other problem
but it starts with us having the
confidence and understanding that
uh
as challenging as this may be
this is something that
will get fixed
in large part because we've got
extraordinary americans with experience
talent dedication who are willing to put
themselves on the front lines
to get things done
i'll have more about uh more to say
about this tomorrow when i have those
workers here but i just want to
emphasize uh how proud i am of the
people who are already
involved in this effort and how
confident i am after speaking to them
that in fact we're going to get this
problem under control all right